president Trump unleashing on Democrats
and his fiercest support yet of is
Supreme Court nominee Brett Kavanaugh I
can tell you that false accusation and
false accusations of all types are made
against a lot of people this is a high
quality person and I certainly hope I
certainly hope it would be a horrible
insult to our country if this doesn't
happen and it'll be a horrible horrible
thing for future political people judges
anything you want there be a horrible
thing it cannot it cannot be allowed to
happen
understand the Democrats are playing a
card game cos a con game
is their institution is there anything
you know it's the con game second has
nothing the second accused it doesn't
even know she thinks maybe put it in him
maybe not
she admits that she was drunk she admits
time-lapses you startled he can't
believe this is happening his wife is
devastated his children are devastated I
don't mean they're like oh gee I'm a
little unhappy they're devastated
meanwhile Senate Democrats are
continuing to prove that the facts don't
matter with a new wave of smears against
Cavanaugh the second thing about that
interview was when he said that he
actually downplayed his drinking and he
said he never really blacked out so he
didn't remember things I mean those are
things that really go to credibility
given some of the stories circulating
out there I've heard from both sides and
I believe dr. Blasi Ford
and I believe miss Ramirez both of their
stories are credible unlike his where he
wouldn't actually answer the question or
say why he wouldn't be interviewed by
the FBI that's not the response of
someone who wants to plead his innocence
it is judge Kavanagh who is seeking a
lifetime appointment to the Supreme
Court and who I think now bears the
burden of disproving these allegations
rather than dr. Ford and miss Ramirez
who should be dismissed with slanderous
accusations
all right Gregg I'm gonna start with you
I think you're a good place to start
all right look they are throwing out the
fundamental
criminal justice system and that is the
right of confrontation the right of
cross-examination these are United
States senators they've already made up
their mind they've heard from her
they've heard from him so what's the
point of having courtrooms and trials in
this country shouldn't we just decide if
we like someone ahead of time yeah you
know what's interesting is that they're
being honest about it now both Coons and
mazie Hirono both have formulated a
fairly chilling response when you ask
about due process they go they'll go
this isn't a court of law you don't need
to do process that's and it's like you
know what they're right they're
basically admitting that we can crucify
you without evidence or any kind of
corroboration because it's not let's
keep it out of the court of law
and let it so you lose what you learn
now is you lose your rights if you're up
for a job so that my solution is
everybody needs to get accusation
insurance because right now though it's
true because right now what they're
saying is I'll go from you know you're
gonna need allegation insurance and the
thing is one last point judge sender you
want to move on we as human beings we
mimic behavior if you look at fashion if
you look at diet you look at social
media we copy each other this kind of
behavior will spread the exception of
simply an allegation - evidence is going
to spread into other areas of our
culture it's already happening you see
it in the workplace you see it in other
places
how do we stop it okay Kennedy how do we
stop it but I'm not gonna finish there
look what we've got is at United States
senators saying that he needs to
disprove a negative how do you disprove
or prove a negative he's got to disprove
that he did this if he wasn't there and
he didn't do it number one how does he
prove that and number two happened the
United States senators shift the burden
of proof it's always on the complainant
well it's actually really smart what her
legal team is doing because they're
coming up with a series of demands that
are almost unbeatable and so essentially
when Republicans on the Senate Judiciary
Committee say well we can't meet those
because they don't meet the standard for
you know the protocol in the Senate but
also I mean that's how our criminal
justice system that's what it's based
upon which essentially follows from
natural law so you're turning all of
that on
head and you can't disprove a negative
common law absolutely and she's right
Kennedy is right Jessie but they're
saying that she's not getting fair and
respectful treatments what say you about
I think the Democrats have been unfair
and disrespectful throughout this whole
process to Cavanaugh with the smears in
the sandbagging listen everything
they've done has been political the
timing the demands the entourage
surrounding this person so you know what
the Republicans said they said okay
let's take politics out of it we're not
going to question her we're going to
appoint a independent sex crimes
prosecutor female who knows what she's
talking about and she will be the ones
to ask the questions not the politicians
and then the Democrats turn around and
scream and said this is unfair this is
going to create a circus they've been
the ones creating the circus here and
this type of person has been used before
in Watergate in iran-contra as well as
mafia hearing so there's nothing new to
get outside attorney bringing in an
outsider to commit there's nothing new
to this and the Democrats are just
complaining because I don't believe that
Ford will look good being questioned by
a female experienced litigator with the
story that she has I think her story
will not hold up well and that's the
reason the Democrats are upset about all
right now no one heard a word here that
indicates because the judge start up by
saying Democrats are smearing judge
Cavanaugh I haven't heard a word of
smear but here that's not a smear talk
for a second and then you can respect oh
but clearly this is not a court this is
a Senate confirmation hearing and you
have an opportunity here for the judge
to testify to say what he ever he wants
right nobody has heard from Miss Ford
yet the second thing to say here is they
are bringing in a woman lawyer because
they've got 11 men on the Republican
side and they are in bed
so they can't win bringing a mad woman
they can't win they can win but that
they've got to do is they've got to give
her a fair opportunity so what our
lawyers have said is hey wait a second
we're not coming in here to be beaten up
by somebody who's a criminal defense or
criminal in that
you refuse to even have the FBI
investigator senators why shouldn't they
do this they refuse to have Marc judge
this guy who's now hiding out who says
that he was involved with drinking ESPA
ksps because once you let one witness
come in they're gonna line up seven or
eight or nine November Jessie you said a
minute ago
Why Why are they rushing this what's
going on wait a second the only reason
why it's being rushed is because
Feinstein Jesse and I can't believe this
you know the words you would say ignore
the woman especially ways here's a
problem okay the the optics of the Anita
Hill questioning were so bad and so
expensive and we cannot have a
repetition of that in this day and age
culture has changed the Senate has
changed Society has changed and we're
also in the middle of a movement and we
don't know how that ends we don't know
like how that permanently changes
society but if you have a problem with
people like Joe Biden and arlen specter
going after a female witness or a female
accuser or someone who's sworn under
oath to testify before this committee
then why not try it differently why not
have someone who's not showboating
because when senators have their chance
like Cory Booker this is my Spartacus
moment that's when it turns into a
circus and you got some people to now
tree and nothin we don't live it because
there's auditioning this is not about a
cross-examination why not how else do we
attest his birth in this country because
you give both people a chance
how do you decide how do you decide
whether or not it's a credible
allegation and whether or not you
believe it whether it's a civil case or
a criminal case every time this is even
more significant like what you see
because this country is going to be
under the rule of a Supreme Court with a
man on it like this and that's why we
need to have a test is the greatest of
credibility I just wonder when I'm in
the war where we go all right you're not
gonna want to miss the five two-wire
because god help me we're missing one
big here he said there was no smear we
had a guy who just crawled under a rock
havin a tea after calling Cavanaugh an
attempted rapist or a game I'm sorry
attempted gang raper and he crawled
under his rock
he made Twitter private so I want to
remind how this is working but to the
public how this works instead of driving
deep on a specific case what you do is
you find a number of specific examples
that alone are not sturdy one Ford two
Ramirez
three you're booked for a vanetti Aven
Eddie's claim so a vennett his claim is
alone what does it mean the yearbook
thing it's just a yearbook what does
that mean the other cases have no weight
no corroboration no witness so
individually they don't match they don't
they're not strong so what you do is you
create an environment of guilt by using
these little things that's what the
Democrats are doing it seems to be
working with the help of the media it is
working because the more complainant you
bring in the fewer that have to be
tested as revenge rules of credibility
that we abused from time immemorial so
these are all idiots in your the year
papel know for willing to stand up and
put them in a show mock exam and they
don't show up what does that tell you
what I would think that does that tell
you what if they don't I don't know what
why do you say that because I wouldn't
you think episode do you think urban
Eddie's gonna show up on TV tonight do
you think it's gonna show no I don't
think that says anything about we'll be
bringing it to you why